the life of a professional esports
athlete
is pretty hectic between all the
practice travel and competition there
really isn't much time to just sit down
and relax basically with screaming and
streaming that takes up like 10 hours a
day literally so it's like you don't
really have that much time elsewhere so
i i basically just like go to the gym
and then scream and stream that takes up
like 14 hours out of the day just doing
that basically but building a community
on twitch can take a long time and when
most of your day is already packed with
scrims and sleep not many top players
are willing to dedicate what's left of
it to the chaos of twitch chat hell some
of the greatest esports competitors in
the entire world like my boy simple only
find time to stream once in a blue moon
because they're just too busy slapping
people around on lan throughout this ct
side oh nice shot from simple alistar
goes for the fight
unable to get the kill
simple isn't happy with one he wants
more more and he gets to stop through
the door another shot lands simple
looking for it he finds a headshot
simple just taking over right now oh
he's going for more than go he's going
for more simple's hitting all the
headshots with the orb and it's gonna be
the ace simple puts narvi to 15.
he just bites everyone but what if i
told you that for shazeeb shazam khan
climbing to the top of valoran's
competitive scene
simply wasn't enough that in spite of
his full-time commitment to bossing a
lineup of absolute mad lad killers he
still makes enough room in his day to
scream laugh and frag for tens of
thousands of valorant fans every single
night oh man no way you guys are getting
all these kills dude remaining what the
[ __ ]
no way
[Music]
sure
and not only is shazam voluntarily
subjecting himself to valorance
matchmaking which let's be honest
doesn't always bring out the best in
everyone get off my ass but he's somehow
able to do so while keeping up an
infectious positive energy
[Applause]
so how is it that shazam has been able
to balance a high level esports career
with an incredibly successful stream
what are his motivations for taking on
such an insane workload and how did it
help him to support his family when they
needed it most
times
[Music]
[Music]
okay so before we dive into shaz's story
please take a second and like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications so that the next time we
release a sentinel's video which we will
uh you can comment and hear shaz scream
a bunch because he does that a lot so
aside from being the igl and mastermind
behind valorent's first world
championship winning roster who is this
27 year old maryland native well when
he's not ripping around in his corvette
or hitting the gym with his teammates
shazam always makes sure to take a
moment to facetime his mom back home but
that's when shaz actually has free time
you see like most esports pros the bulk
of his day is spent sharpening his
skills in scrims and in spite of winning
countless events with sentinels over the
past year probably the most impressive
thing about shaz is that he somehow
finds the drive to stream an additional
seven to eight hours of valorant every
night
i
actually running and shooting and while
most players spend their time in ranked
raging shazam is kind of just vibing
jamming out to lil uzi vert and
generally having a good time with
whoever he has along for the ride look
down look down you go under it no you
can't then you go under it limbo limbo
yeah you gotta look down look down
[Laughter]
[Music]
now what's interesting is that unlike a
lot of valorent's biggest content
creators jazz didn't jump on the
streaming bandwagon with the game's
release in fact a lot of you valor and
kitties probably don't know this but
shaz has actually been streaming since
most of you were about to twinkle in
your father's nut sack
twinkle in your father's doesn't make
any sense who wrote this bro if you have
a twinkle in your nut sack like
you're gonna get that checked out it's
it's actually crazy um
i've been streaming since 2011 when
justin.tv became twitch.tv i started off
streaming counter-strike source bugs and
then streaming csgo when i was in high
school in college i remember like me and
summit were competing for the number one
slot we went like 300 400 years back
then like i decided to go pro and like i
quit streaming for a bit and someone
went full time it was probably for the
best for summit since uh we all saw his
pro career go up
in the flames from it
no
you know i had to
anyway between the training and
traveling to events that his pursuit of
a cs go career demanded shazam wasn't
able to spare much time for streaming
now he would still stream here and there
but the rigorous schedule of a pro
player prevented him from going live
consistently to build an audience don't
get me wrong he loved being on the road
you get so caught up in like little
things in life or whatever like in your
own community but when you travel you
realize there's just like so much more
exposure to different cultures and
people like all around the world it's
like the most humbling experience so i'm
glad i got to travel i got to see the
world rather than like spend a lot of
that time in my apartment i wouldn't
trade those experiences for anything now
as much as shazam was relishing the pro
gamer life in late 2019 his cs go career
hit an unexpected wall when complexity
dropped him after a poor showing at the
berlin major and if things didn't seem
like they could get any worse
they certainly did when kovan 19 rolled
around and turned the world on its head
with strict travel restrictions being
implemented globally shazam found
himself grounded at home and even though
it initially felt like his wings were
being clipped by the pandemic the world
shutting down presented shaz with the
opportunity to rededicate himself to
streaming and luckily for him the timing
couldn't have been better valerent was
taking twitch by storm and seeing its
potential as an esport shaz went all in
on the game and in what felt like
seemingly no time his commitments to the
grind had earned him a spot on
sentinel's new roster
guys i killed the seagull
yeah he's garage though
as sentinels and shazam started to
dominate the north american valorant
scene more eyeballs began following him
over to his stream each night but they
weren't necessarily tuning in to see the
big brain of valoran's best team getting
sweaty and ranked no you see shaz
doesn't exactly play the same way in
officials as he does on stream despite
top fragging in most of his ranked games
he's often messing around and trying
things that would never really work in a
pro setting you know let me res you know
oh so you said i'm gonna die
but for shazam streaming isn't only
about creating viral highlights of his
best plays it's also been the perfect
platform for him to engage with his fans
streaming for me was never just playing
the game because i play the game all day
anyways it was more so like the
interactions just like trying to have a
good time like you know when i get
ranked and play with different people
like regardless of like we're just
playing volleyball like i think it's
more fun when it becomes a social
experience and i think people can relate
to that a lot more and shazam's
supporters aren't the only ones who
enjoy his on-stream antics either other
high-level players have also come to
appreciate the energy he brings to their
matches in ranked like sometimes it gets
like tilting you get tired out and stuff
like that so when you have like shaz on
your team you know there's always going
to be good vibes it's always high energy
and like sometimes you'll be losing but
you're still feeling like you're winning
just because like the vibes are so high
you're like wait wait we're losing i
don't know how he does it honestly like
after practicing and like jimmy and
stuff like i have no energy personally
so it's kind of crazy
where is my mind yeah
why what
go back go back
since sentinel's win in iceland back in
may shazam stream has exploded over the
past three months he averaged more than
11 000 viewers per stream and his sub
count has increased by the same amount
plenty of new faces have stopped by his
stream because it has become the place
to be if you want to watch high
skill high energy valorant late at night
and although some of his new viewers
might be a little surprised by all the
yelling and screaming he does his og
followers have come to expect it so it's
kind of funny because
now everything's going up and like
people are singing it but that's kind of
been like my stream since the very
beginning i used to have longer practice
days on my counter-strike teams and then
immediately after i'd make a coffee and
then like load up the stream and stream
fl all night like high energy lots of
noise complaints
but shazam's recent success on twitch is
not something that he takes for granted
after the tragic unexpected death of his
father late last year he's become even
more motivated to work harder and
support his mom and thankfully his
stream has allowed him to do just that i
wanted to build some sort of like
stable income mostly because like
esports is volatile like you know
players get dropped never know what
happens you know your kiki dropped like
i've been through it all and so my
stream became a way to like take care of
everything back home taking over
everything from my mom and stuff that
was like the biggest thing for me was
that now like i've got some sort of
stability where like i can tell my mom
like i've got her handled obviously
after everything that happened and while
it can be kind of difficult to
comprehend how he can balance such a
crazy workload the fact that he can has
made the community appreciate him even
more
[Music]
i'm happy for him because uh
like i said like what he does like
practicing probably six hours a day
minimum and then doing all that and like
what he went through this year and still
like finding time to stream eight to
nine hours a day he's on the grind like
it's hard to do that especially
streaming like people understand it's
mentally draining especially with like
something like valerian ranked like that
can actually like drain you a lot the
facts he keeps his energy high is like
insane for shazam the grind
never stops even after streaming and
playing professionally for over a decade
he still has an unbelievable
unquenchable thirst to succeed and while
other players might struggle with
burnout he's always happy to share
what's left of his free time putting a
smile on his fans faces
i i always enjoyed it it's just fun
playing the game like interacting with
people it sounds like cliche i guess but
something i've always like really
enjoyed and to see it love is kind of
insane because i didn't expect it people
always ask me like what could have been
if you stuck to streaming like if you
stuck back then like one of the og's but
um it's cool to see so now even with
valorent pros preparing for the game's
busiest time of the year don't be
surprised if you find shazam doing what
he loves almost
every night
dumpstering fools on twitch
and acting like a maniac while he does
it
what the [ __ ] is that
i think it's the lucy vert i think
you're not supposed to say a little uzi
bear i think keith made fun of me for
for people or made fun of people who
said that i don't know who little woozy
music is guys
that's better than a little super little
lucy bear
lil uziver keith is just he's just dying
right now like he's actually just just
having a stroke as we speak